للياسانيين طرق عباده قريبه من الاديان
السماويه ويظهر فيها تاثرهم بتلك الاديان
حيث لهم ايام للصوم وقبله للتوجه اليها
اثناء الصلاه للتطهر من الذنوب
نوعان من الصيام الاول صيام كار حيث نصوم
ثلاثه ايام واليوم الرابع يكون العيد
وصيام عيد اقوال تاسست وهذا عاده ما يكون
في اربعينيه الشتاء وهو ايضا صيام لي
ثلاثه ايام ويكون العيد في اليوم الرابع
كذلك نحن نؤدي فريضه الصلاه وهي صلاه
الفجر وصلاه المغرب ومثل الاديان الاخرى
فالانسان في حاجه الى التواصل مع الله
وذلك يتم عن طريق الصلاه وعند صلاه الفجر
نتوجه نحو شروق الشمس وفي صلاه المغرب
نتوجه نحو الشمس عند غروبها وفي كلتا
الصلاتين نترجى رحمه الله اما ماذا نتوجه
نحو الشمس لاننا نعتقد ان ضوء الشمس هو
ضوء الله ونحن لا نعبد الشمس كما يتصور
البعض بل نعتقد انها رمز لنور الله
كما يعرف الكاكائي بشواربه العريضه التي
تعتبر ركنا اساسيا للرجال الكتائئيين
له رمزيه خاصه وهو احد الرموز التي تميز
بها اتباع الديانه اليارسانيه ووجود شارب
يعني التزام الشخص بدينه ولكن هذا لا يعني
ان الشخص الذي يحلق شاربه ليس بكائه كلا
هو سيبقى ككايا ولكنه مبتعدون عن الالتزام
بدينه كما يحدث عند المسلمين هناك بعضهم
لا يصلي وهذا لا يعني انه ليس بالمسلم
ولكنه غير ملتزم باحد اركانه
يعبروا عن مدى التزام
الشخصيه صباحا وانظر في المراه الاساسيه